se activa de forma gradual la producción
en shanghai luego de verse afectada por
una ola de contagios de kobe 19 que
obligó a la ciudad de entrar a un
estricto confinamiento el gobierno está
promoviendo políticas para que el centro
financiero vuelva de forma rápida y
ordenada a sus actividades habituales en
una de las primeras etapas para volver a
la normalidad están enfocados en la
reactivación empresarial
hasta el domingo un total de 2.021
empresas de los sectores industrial
comercial y de servicios en el distrito
de bouziane han activado sus negocios y
producción unos 62.000 empleados han
regresado a sus puestos
en más del 80% de las empresas en el
distrito de minhang están acelerando la
reanudación del negocio de manera
ordenada
el gobierno ofrece a los empresarios
incentivos económicos para lograr la
reapertura de sus actividades y así
minimizar el impacto en las cadenas de
suministro de las micro pequeñas y
medianas empresas de diversos rubros la
reactivación en shanghai llega en
momentos de una disminución de contagios
a nivel nacional incluidas las cifras
registradas en beijing
la cantidad de casos de kobe 19 en
beijing ha disminuido significativa
durante ocho días consecutivos y no ha
habido muestras de nuevas infecciones
comunitarias durante tres días
consecutivos sin tombini a pesar de la
caída en la incidencia del virus el
portavoz del gobierno de beijing aseguró
que se mantendrán los esfuerzos de
prevención y control de la pandemia
luego de que se registrara un nuevo
brote de contagios por kobe 19 este
lunes por lo que exhortó a las
comunidades afectadas a seguir las
normas y mantener el aislamiento a los
funcionarios los llamo a garantizar los
suministros necesarios en las áreas
donde se aplica actualmente las
restricciones a la movilidad